you know nothing about him you know  nothing about what hitler did in 1932  dachau concentration camp in his first  50 days  the race purity laws in his first  hundred days and you dare say  you dare say that hillary zionism  racist remarks go and check your history  history that was the policy they ran on  the nazi policy yes you read mind camp  yes what did mankind say about zionism i  mean  what did my cancer about zionism it was  a mad time and his highness he wanted to  kill all jews  but his policy in 32 when he won that  election was to deport germany's jews to  israel  and the zionist movement had secret  meetings with his administration  talking about that